hey guys how's it going today is the
launch of the apple watch they
officially have been shipped out i have
got mine here my sister waited by the
door for me all day thanks jen you're
welcome so we're about to do an unboxing
and a setup and then tomorrow i will do
some initial first impression reactions
after using it for at least 24 hours but
let's get down to it i've got my knife
this was the biggest kitchen knife that
i could find
nice light slice
oh man this is a sharp knife this would
if i cooked this would cut some meat
oh okay
slice
wow this knife is incredibly sharp i
gotta be careful
okay let's remove this
apple watch logo there
yeah who cares let's open it
the one that i'm currently unboxing is
the 38 millimeter sport edition with a
white band so hopefully that's what's
actually in here actually i hope they
surprise me and have a steal one with a
link band what do we have in here
we've got some instructions
oh good thing i didn't toss this aside
because apparently
this is one side of the band so i may
actually need this the best part about
these is you guys can switch out these
bands super easy
anything else in here just let me just
double check let me show you how sharp
this knife is first of all like look at
this
like it just
a slice through your heart wait medium
large oh
don't want that
except we have the charger look at you
i'm gonna use this knife every
opportunity i get
oh it's long look how long this is
sticky
unstick you
come on stick you something you've never
seen before basic charging brick i don't
know where they go i lose them so often
all right screw this stuff i i don't
even care about it
anything else in here no
there's a nice little tab that says
nothing it's an arrow pull here
oh it felt real smooth
real
smooth
here's the case
are you ready
are you ready come and get it na na na
it looks just like it looks in the store
all right we've got some instructions on
the back here it says one two three
shows you how to put it on
i'll figure it out myself i'll figure it
out myself i am smart
i'm a wise human
oh it smells nice
is that the button that i oh it's
turning on it's booting up
do something
is something happening or now should i
put it on so most people usually put
their watches this way but i'm a lefty
having a little bit of a struggle
putting it on by myself as soon as i
have placed it on the wrist the magic
has started to happen
so it's gonna be a little upside down
for you guys but um english please
open the apple watch app and start your
iphone to start pairing it says hold
watch
up to the camera and align it with the
viewfinder
all right
just like do it
okay well the
pair automatically is not working okay
open why are you not working like it's
so freaking simple click start pairing
sassed up right now start pairing
hello
hello why why you gotta be so rude so
finally our code has now showed up so
we're gonna enter our code
it's telling me that my apple watch is
now paired
apple watch is now currently syncing
so we're gonna give this
some time
and
we'll see what happens
all right guys so the apple watch is now
officially all set up i'm pretty excited
i don't want to do a full review at this
time because i haven't had a chance to
actually play with it but i'm pretty
pretty excited about it so here we are
all the apps
let's let's play a song shall we i
wonder what song i've got on here
what do you want to
guess i don't think it is
oh mumford and sons been real
into this song
okay stop playing shut up i'm gonna
message the group
oh i'm gonna send these oh my gosh jen
tell me if you get this emoji did you
get it
i got a text that says what's up oh my
gosh one animated emoji attached well
you didn't you didn't show up it's a
heart but it's like scooting around yeah
scooting
it's freaking cheesy that's real cheesy
so anyway i'm gonna post some photos and
stuff on my blog so check that out
ijustine.com i also have a video from
yesterday when i went to visit the
maxfield line here in los angeles which
was one of the only stores in the u.s
that actually was selling apple watches
day one of launch that's all i have for
you in this unboxing video i'll do a
more thorough review
very soon
and i'm gonna go play with my watch now
i think that's what i'm gonna do siri
text jenna is eric and tell her that she
is a pig
do you get it it says she is a pig
that's what i said yeah she's a pig huh
cool
bye oh what happened something is
happening
oh pittsburgh verse new york rangers
start